Professor Charles
Bailyn: We've been talking
about the Type Ia
Supernovae and the data that
they provide about the expansion
and, as it turns out,
acceleration of the Universe.
And so, one way to summarize
all that information is that
what we have found out--we now
know that the Universe is
accelerating,
not just expanding,
but accelerating.
And that acceleration comes
about because of some kind of
dark energy--or to turn it
around,
the label we give to whatever
is calling that is dark energy.
And this sometimes gets
summarized by this quantity,
which is the energy density of
the dark energy relative to the
critical density of the
Universe.
And the fact that it's
accelerating means that this
quantity must be greater than
this other quantity,
the density of matter,
because the matter tends to
pull things together.
And so, we know not only that
it's accelerating,
we know something about how
much it is accelerating,
and that tells us how much
bigger the dark energy density
is than the matter density.
And we kind of know by how much.
We kind of know how much bigger
this is than the dark matter
density.
But somebody actually asked the
question that,
you know, I keep saying,
well, this is like 3/4,
and this is like 1/4.
If you add a bunch of matter,
couldn't you just add a bunch
of dark energy also,
and end up with the same amount
of acceleration?
So, a comparable Universe.
And the answer is,
yes, you could.
There's nothing in the
supernova data that prohibits
this from being .5 and this from
being 1,
as long as this is sufficiently
greater than that by the amount
necessary to give rise to the
observed acceleration.
And so, if you plot these two
quantities against each
other--so, here's,
kind of, 0,0.
Actually, this can be negative,
but let's not go there.
1,1.
What you find out is that
there's a kind of allowed region
that sort of looks like this,
allowed by the supernova data.
Notice, this is--I'm assuming
throughout that the dark energy
really is the Cosmological
Constant.
I'm not thinking about Big Rip
scenarios at the moment,
because that would add a third
dimension to this plot,
and I don't want to do that
just yet.
So, this is all assuming that
dark energy is the Cosmological
Constant.
But that's certainly a place to
start.
There's no reason not to do
that.
And so, I've been kind of
consistently claiming,
as we've been talking about the
course, that the real answer is
somewhere like here.
Yeah?
That it's about .3 on the
matter side, .25 and about
3/4,2/3,3/4 on the dark energy
side.
But, in fact,
you could go--as far as the
supernova care,
you could have no matter at all
and just a little dark energy,
or you could have a lot of
matter and a huge amount of dark
energy.
And you'd get the amount of
acceleration,
and therefore,
satisfy the observational
constraints.
But, in fact,
it turns out,
we know more than this,
because there are other
constraints on cosmology besides
the supernovae.
And, I have to tell you at this
point that this course,
the way I've presented it,
is a little bit lopsided,
because the other ways of
constraining these two
quantities are just as important
as the supernovae,
and I'm going to do them all in
one lecture.
And this is kind of in the
spirit of the philosophy of this
course, where we try and
understand a few things in
depth,
rather than many things in
breadth.
But I'm going to talk about two
other kinds of constraints on
cosmology today,
which are, in fact,
just as important to modern
cosmology as the supernovae are.
I like the supernovae,
first of all,
because they were the first
evidence of dark energy.
I still think they're the best
But it's also true that I think
they're, in some ways,
the easiest to understand.
That's not quite right.
What I mean is that you don't
need a whole bunch of physics to
understand what's going on,
because it's just the expansion
of the Universe,
whereas some of these other
things,
as you will see,
there's moments where I'm going
to have to say,
and then there's a whole bunch
of complicated physics,
and then, you get the result.
And so, it's less satisfying to
teach, and perhaps to learn,
in a course like this,
but equally important for
modern cosmology.
And what these other things do
is they pick out where in the
allowed region--region allowed
from the supernovae,
the real Universe actually is.
Okay.
So, with the understanding that
either of the two things I'm
about to talk about could have
been five weeks of this course,
let's move in and I'll try and
explain, in brief,
what these things tell us about
the Universe.
The first is the Cosmic
Microwave Background.
This, we've encountered before.
This was one of the proofs that
the Big Bang really happened,
as opposed to the "steady
state."
And, I don't know if you
remember what we said about
that, so, let me remind you.
Recall what was going on.
You're looking back in time as
you look far away.
So, as you look back,
things are denser and hotter.
And if you look back far
enough, they get really hot.
So, let us imagine,
we're looking at a redshift not
of 1 or .8 or something like
that, but at a redshift of
3,000.
So, this is when the Universe
was--the scale factor of the
Universe was 3,000 times smaller
than it is today.
At that time,
the average temperature of the
Universe, about 10,000 degrees.
Turns out, that's an
interesting number,
because 10,000 degrees is how
hot it has to be for hydrogen to
ionize.
Ionization, you'll remember,
is when the electrons
disassociate with the protons,
and then, you just have a whole
bunch of charged particles
moving around.
And it turns out--so,
before that,
when the temperature is higher
than this,
you imagine that the entire
Universe is basically filled
with all this ionized hydrogen.
One of the features of ionized
hydrogen, or indeed,
charged particles,
generally, is that they tend to
be opaque.
Photons don't propagate well
through these things.
Photons propagate well through
neutral materials but not well
through charged materials.
So, before that,
the Universe was opaque.
It's like looking at the
surface of a star or a big wall
of opaque gas.
You can't see any further.
So, it can't look back any
further than that.
But if you look in any
direction, and you're looking
far enough away,
you ought to see a big wall of
10,000-degree hydrogen.
And, in fact,
we know what a wall of
10,000-degree hydrogen looks
like, because there are stars
whose surfaces are 10,000
degrees.
And the Sun's a little cooler
than that, but there are many
stars that are 10,000 degrees.
So, this should look like--so,
in any direction you look,
you should see something that
looks like the surface of a
star: hot ionized hydrogen.
And this looks like the surface
of a star.
And we know that that's wrong,
right?
You can--let's go outside and
look up in some direction.
If this were really true,
then anywhere you look,
you would see the surface of a
star that's hotter and brighter
than the Sun.
And so, the whole of the sky
would look like the surface of
the Sun, only hotter.
And obviously,
that isn't the case.
And the reason that that's not
the case is because you have to
remember how redshifted this is.
It's redshifted by a factor of
3,000.
So, the light has wavelengths
that's 3,000 times longer than
the light we see from stars.
So, let's work that out.
You'll recall,
λ that you observed is equal
to λ_emitted,
plus Δλ.
Or, is equal to
λ_emitted (1 +
Z), because Z is
Δλ / λ_emitted.
And so, this is equal to the
wavelength emitted,
times 3,001,
right?
Here's the 1, here's the 3,000.
We'll call that 3 x 10^(3).
And if the wavelength that's
emitted is a nice optical
wavelength like 5 x 10^(-7)
meters,
that looks green or yellow,
times 3,000,
that's 15 x 10^(-4).
That's around 1 millimeter.
Wavelengths of a millimeter.
Now, wavelengths of a
millimeter, you don't see with
your eye.
These are, more or less,
what we call microwaves.
So, the prediction really is
that in any direction you look,
you see a whole--you see what
would have been something that
looks like the surface of a
star,
except it's redshifted so far
that all you can see is
microwaves instead of ordinary
optical light.
This is true.
This has been verified
observationally,
first in the 1960s.
This is true.
There is a Cosmic Microwave
Background in any direction.
Take a microwave detector,
radio telescope.
You point it in any direction.
You see this stuff coming from
the Universe.
And this was taken,
when it was first discovered,
as evidence for the Big Bang
and against the steady state.
Because it was predicted by the
Big Bang, because you assume
that the Universe was much,
much hotter and much,
much denser in the past,
which is what you need in order
to create this stuff,
and that by the time you're
seeing it now,
it's all redshifted.
Okay, so that's fine,
as far as it goes.
One of the features of the
Cosmic Microwave Background
turns out to be that it's very
smooth.
And you expect that to be true,
because you expect to see the
exact same thing in any
direction.
It doesn't matter if you go
back in time looking that way,
or back in time looking that
way.
You expect the Universe to be
denser and hotter in the past
and about the same way.
And so, sure enough,
the Cosmic Microwave Background
is pretty much the same
everywhere you look.
Same everywhere.
And, as further experiments
were done, it really is very
smooth.
And it came--it started to--
the smoothness of this started
to become a little embarrassing,
because it can't be--you don't
want it to be perfectly smooth.
Absolutely, totally identical
in all directions.
Because the Universe,
at the moment,
is not perfectly smooth.
We've got planets.
We got people.
We got galaxies.
Then, we got big spaces where
there's nothing.
And so, if the Universe,
at the time of the Cosmic
Microwave Background,
is going to evolve into our own
Universe now,
there must be some little
perturbations that are going to
grow up to be galaxies later on.
If it were perfectly smooth
then, it would have to be
perfectly smooth now,
and that's manifestly not the
case.
So, you suspect that there must
be some irregularities,
because the Universe now is
clearly irregular,
in the sense that it contains
objects of various kinds.
And so, in the 1990s,
it turns out,
you can see microwaves from the
ground, but it's better to do it
from space.
And so, in the 1990s,
they launched a satellite
called COBE.
This is the Cosmic Background
Explorer.
This is a satellite launched in
the early 1990s.
And COBE finally found the
variations in the Cosmic
Microwave Background.
And they were very small,
ten--1 part in 100,000.
So, 10^(-5) to 1.
Now, that contrasts with the
variations we see in the current
Universe.
In the current Universe,
the variations in density can
be 30 orders of magnitude,
10^(30).
Remember, the average density
of the Universe is something
like 10^(-27) kilograms per
cubic meter.
In here, we've got 10^(3)
kilograms per cubic meter.
That's the density of water,
for example.
And so, the density of the
Universe now varies by 10^(30),
but then, it only varied by
10^(-5).
So, the sixth decimal place in
the density was found to be
variable.
The first five were always the
same.
Now, 10^(30).
And so, that seems like this
Universe is quite different from
this Universe.
But there are ways that
structure grows and that,
I'll come back to in a minute.
That's the second thing I want
to talk about,
is the growth of structure.
But, at least,
there was some variation.
People were very excited about
this, because this,
again, is a situation where
something was predicted,
and then, you build a
complicated piece of apparatus,
and you see what you predict.
And that's always a good thing
to have happen.
That gives you confidence that
you know what you're talking
about.
And in their excitement,
a number of scientists became,
sort of, overexcited.
There's a famous quote from
Stephen Hawking.
At the time,
he said--about the COBE
results, he said it's like
seeing the face of God.
This is a very dangerous thing
to say, because,
you know, most people in the
world don't understand how
similes work.
So, he said,
it's like seeing the face of
God.
And this was reported:
Scientist Sees God.
So, you have to watch what you
say.
And, you know,
the Weekly World News
got a hold of this and then it
was trouble.
All right.
So, they saw God by seeing the
variations in the Cosmic
Microwave Background.
Who knew?
All right, now, then.
So, that was nice,
but COBE was just the first
crack at this.
And, while they saw variations,
they didn't see it very
precisely.
It was a pretty blurry image.
So, then, there was another
satellite, still operating,
actually, called WMAP.
WMAP is the Wilkinson Microwave
Anisotropy Probe.
So, anisotropy means
irregularity.
Wilkinson--Dave Wilkinson was
one of the pioneers of this kind
of radio astronomy,
and he was the leader of this
project until he died shortly
before launch,
and so, then,
they named it after him.
And then, in 2003,
WMAP announced its results,
and they got a much more
precise map of the Cosmic
Microwave Background;
so precise that they could
measure the size of these
irregularities.
Not just how irregular they
were, but how big they were.
And that, it turns out,
gives you cosmological
information.
And I'll come back to that in a
second.
But I want to start by showing
you some pictures,
here.
Let's see. All right.
This is the COBE results.
So, let me explain what you're
looking at.
What you're looking at is a map
of the entire sky.
They've projected it onto the
sky.
And the way it works is this.
Down the middle here,
that's the plane of the galaxy.
That's where the Milky Way is
going to be.
And then, any position on the
sky maps onto this oval.
And so, this is a common way of
expressing the whole sky.
Now, this is actually kind of
the raw data,
where red--I can't remember
which way it goes.
I think red is slightly denser,
or actually,
slighter hotter,
is the way they measure it,
and blue is slightly cooler.
So, there's this kind of
yin-yang pattern here.
And that's because we're moving
in some direction through the
Universe.
And so, if you look at the
Microwave Background in the
direction we're moving,
then it's a little bit
blueshifted, which makes it look
a little bit hotter.
Whereas, if you look back where
we're coming from,
that's a little bit redshifted,
so it looks a little cooler.
And so, we're moving in this
direction, away from here,
and that effect--it's a very
small effect of our motion
through the Universe--turns out
to dominate the irregularities
in the Cosmic Microwave
Background.
But, of course,
that's not what we care about.
We want to see what the
background itself is doing.
It's also true that that's
quite easy to remove,
because we know how fast we're
moving.
You can tell from this what
direction we're moving in,
and also how fast.
And you can just take that out
of the whole map,
and adjust the map to be how we
would see it if we weren't
moving anywhere.
That looks like this.
And now, there's a clear signal.
This is the Milky Way, here.
There are sources of microwaves
that aren't the Cosmic Microwave
Background.
They're objects in our own
galaxy that emit a lot of
microwaves.
But the thing is that the
spectrum of the microwaves they
emit is very different from the
spectrum of the Cosmic Microwave
Background.
And so, if you take not just an
image of this,
but you take an actual
spectrum,
which they did,
you can tell the difference
between things coming--emission
coming from the background,
and emission coming from actual
objects in our own galaxy.
And so, you can take out the
ones--you can artificially,
digitally, remove the objects
that have the spectrum
associated with galactic
objects.
And so, you can do that.
You can take this out.
And that's what you end up.
I should say that the scale
between red and blue changes by
about a factor of 10 between
each one of these plots.
And so, the difference between
red and blue,
here, is much,
much smaller than the
difference between red and blue
up here.
Anyway, this was the face of
God, according to Hawking,
because it wasn't smooth,
and because you could,
after some exhaustive error
analysis, convince yourself that
you really believe that these
pieces of the Cosmic Microwave
Background are actually hotter,
and therefore denser,
than these pieces of the Cosmic
Microwave Background.
So, that was a big triumph.
And these irregularities,
then, grow up to be galaxies,
or groups of galaxies,
or groups of groups of
galaxies, because,
you know, they're pretty big.
They extend,
you know, some significant
fraction across the whole
Universe.
This is, you know,
a map of the whole Universe,
because it's mapping the entire
sky.
So, they're not going to grow
up to be individual galaxies,
but they are going to grow up
to be irregularities in the
Universe.
Okay, so now,
this is COBE in the 1990s.
To compare that to the WMAP
results.
Here is, on a different
visualization color scheme.
WMAP changed colors on us so
that you wouldn't get confused
between their results and the
COBE results.
So, this is the COBE map again
and this is what WMAP saw.
And you can see that it's
seeing the same things.
This over-density here,
that's this stuff here.
This over here,
that's these,
only it's seeing it much,
much, much more precisely.
And, you know,
it's kind of the difference
between a Hubble Space Telescope
image and a ground-based image.
It's seeing the same thing,
but the resolution here is
much, much higher.
And you can see that you might
have a chance of measuring the
size of some of these clumps in
this image in a way that you
wouldn't be able to do in this
image here.
And so, that was what WMAP was
about, was actually measuring
the sizes of these little bumps
in the Cosmic Microwave
Background.
So, why is that a good thing to
do?
And here's where,
if I had five weeks,
I'd explain that to you,
but I don't,
so I won't.
So, let me just say that from
the sizes, you can get
cosmological information.
And I'm not going to tell you
how that works.
Basically, it comes about
because if you--what you find
out from this is that there are
certain sizes-- the clumps like
to be certain sizes,
and there are very few clumps
that are other sizes,
so they're particularly favored
sizes.
And the favored sizes turn out
to relate to how old the
Universe is at that moment and
what has been contained in the
Universe up until then.
But I won't go into that in any
more detail except to say that
the outcome of this is that what
you constrain,
what you find out from this is
what they refer to
Ω_tot,
which is the sum of
Ω_λ and
Ω_matter.
And this turns out to be equal
to 1, to as close as they've
been able to measure it.
It's about 10% by now.
One, probably plus or minus,
I don't know,
0.1.
It's maybe a little better than
that by now, a few percent.
But now, that's a very good
thing to know.
Because, remember what this
looked like from the supernovae
alone.
The allowed region of the--so,
here's 1 and 1.
The allowed region of the
supernovae looks something like
this.
The Cosmic Microwave Background
has these two things equaling 1,
and so, you force yourself to
be on a straight line that looks
like that.
And so, the two of these
experiments put together gives
you a much better constraint on
what's going on.
So, this is from the Microwave
Background.
It's actually some kind of
region that looks like this.
And so, now,
you've got an allowed region
that's much smaller than either
of these two experiments
individually.
Okay, as I said,
there's a third constraint and
this comes about by the growth
of structure.
You have to get from these tiny
perturbations that,
after great effort,
have been seen in the Cosmic
Microwave Background,
those had better grow up to be
galaxies or groups of galaxies
or something.
So, at Z = 3,000 you
have 10^(-5) perturbations.
At Z = 0,
you have 10^(30) plus--even
greater than that,
you know.
Basically a black hole is
infinitely dense,
so I guess you could have
infinite perturbations,
if you think about it from that
point of view.
And you've got to get from one
to the other.
So, how does this work?
Supposing you have a slight
over-density.
Well, what happens?
The region that is over-dense,
a little denser than the stuff
around it, has more gravity than
the surrounding regions.
And so, it then pulls in
material from the neighboring
areas, because the gravitational
force on any particular piece of
mass will put it toward the
place where the matter is
densest,
because that's where the
gravity is coming from.
Pulls in nearby material.
But, of course,
that action makes it denser,
because it's just pulled in
more stuff from the nearby
region, and it makes the other
parts less dense.
And so, this is a runaway
process.
Then, the denser regions are
denser still.
They have yet more gravity.
They pull stuff in even faster.
And so, you can start with tiny
perturbations,
and they grow and grow and grow
and grow,
until it becomes the difference
between a galaxy and not a
galaxy, or a group of galaxies.
Turns out that the--even on the
WMAP plot, the kinds of
perturbations we're looking at
are what's called large--this
leads to the Large-Scale
Structure,
which is distributions of
galaxies and galaxy clusters.
So, there's individual galaxies.
Galaxies like to live in
clusters.
Turns out, the clusters are
grouped together.
That's the Large-Scale
Structure.
And you can plot this by
using--by doing galaxy surveys.
And the problem with the galaxy
survey is, how do you know where
it is in the third dimension?
How do you know how far away it
is?
So, you have position in the
sky.
That tells you two of the
coordinates of a galaxy.
And then, you measure its
redshift.
And you use the redshift in
order to make a guess at how far
away it is, just from using the
Hubble Law.
So, instead of trying to
determine the distance in order
to measure the value of the
Hubble Constant,
you assume a value of the
Hubble Constant that you take
from somewhere.
And then, if you measure--then,
you can--and,
once you've assumed the value
of the Hubble Constant,
you can use redshift to tell
you what the distance is
supposed to be.
And so, then,
you get a 3D map of the sky,
and that tells us what the
structure is now.
You can then compare that
to--you can then simulate the
growth of structure by computer.
You start with the Cosmic
Microwave Background,
with what you know about the
Cosmic Microwave Background.
You apply the laws of gravity.
And you can also put it in a
little dark energy if you feel
like, to change how the--and
that actually does change how
the growth works,
as you might imagine.
But you can stick in any
cosmological parameters you
want, and just apply them as the
Universe grows from a redshift
of 3,000 to now.
And then, you determine what
the simulation looks like now,
where now is defined to be,
you know, 13.7 billion years
after you start.
And you ask, does it look alike?
Look the same as the
observations?
Now, along the way,
when you're applying gravity in
all this stuff,
you have to assume cosmological
parameters--how much dark energy
there is,
but especially,
how much dark matter there is.
Because, it's the matter that's
pulling these density
perturbations together--how much
dark matter and some of its
properties.
And so, then,
what you do is you just run
your computer program a whole
bunch of times,
over and over again,
with different amounts of dark
energy, dark matter,
and stuff like that.
And you see which one of these
simulations produces a Universe
that actually looks like the one
we see.
So, which input parameters give
you the observations?
So, this is,
in general, how computational
science works.
This is how,
you know, the big global
warming models,
all these kinds of things of
work this way.
You put in as much physics,
as much chemistry,
whatever, as you can
understand.
Make a big computer simulation.
You pick a set of starting
conditions.
In this case,
that's easy,
because you observe the Cosmic
Microwave Background.
You run the thing for a while,
and you ask,
does it look like real life?
And to the extent that it looks
like real life,
you believe that you've put in
all the important physics and
all the important science into
your simulation.
Then you ask,
all right, given the results of
this simulation that seems to
represent real life,
what does it predict?
So, you can do things,
for example,
in the global warming models,
you add a whole bunch of carbon
to the atmosphere,
and then you ask,
now what's going to happen?
And with various results.
And so, this is a kind of
example of a general kind of
science that is now more and
more frequently being done--this
kind of computational simulation
of reality,
which you then check in some
way against reality.
And then, to the extent that it
works, you use it to predict
reality in other sets of
circumstances.
So, let me show you some of
that.
All right.
Here's a map of the Universe.
These are observations.
This is a famous redshift
survey.
So, what you've got is redshift
going up this way,
or actually,
they plotted in velocity and
position on the sky in this
direction.
This is kind of a slice of the
Universe, so it's got no third
dimension coming out of the
blackboard, because they just
haven't used it.
And, you can see,
each dot is a galaxy.
They are not distributed
randomly in this plot.
This little guy,
here, is obviously hugely
over-dense.
And there are also places--they
think they're complete out to
the edge here.
There are also places where
they're almost no galaxies.
These are called voids.
There are walls and voids.
And then, as they took more and
more slices to build up the
third dimension,
they ended up having things
that look like this.
And there are clear
over-densities at certain--this
is named the Great Wall.
There are clear over-densities
in some places and clear
under-densities in others.
And it turns out that the
Large-Scale Structure of the
Universe is sort of like a
bubble, some soap bubbles.
And so, they've got walls,
and then, there are voids in
the middle of the walls.
And where those walls connect
are particularly dense clumps.
Another way you can think about
it is that there are these kinds
of these filaments,
things that go through space
where there are unusually large
numbers of galaxies.
So, the most recent redshift
survey, which goes out much,
much further than the one I
just showed you,
that was the first.
That one sort of goes out to
here.
But now they've the 2DF,
Two Degree Field.
This is a telescope that can
look at--measure the redshifts
of galaxies within two degrees
of each other all at the same
time.
So, you get many,
many redshifts.
I think they have close
to--maybe 100,000 redshifts.
Here.
Each blue dot is a galaxy.
And you can see the structure.
You can see the structure
really cleanly with these void
areas surrounded by walls.
And then, when the walls run
into each other,
there are particularly dense
clumps of galaxies.
So, that's the current
structure of the Universe that
we want our simulation to end up
looking like.
Yes?
Student: Why does
[Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
because after around here,
they stop being complete.
They just don't see all the
galaxies, because there are
faint ones that they can't
measure.
And so, beyond about here,
they're just not measuring all
the galaxies that are there.
Okay, so now,
let me show you a simulation.
Let's see. Come on.
Here we go. All right.
I'll come back and I'll tell
you what you're looking at in
just a second.
But here is the evolution of
the Universe as done by
computer.
All right.
So now, let me--where are we
starting from?
The redshift is up here.
And so, we're going to go from
a redshift of about thirty,
when the Universe was thirty
times smaller than it is,
to a redshift of zero,
which is today.
And we're going to look at this
box.
This is a little chunk of the
Universe.
Each one of these dots is
supposed to be a galaxy.
Now, at a redshift of thirty,
they're not galaxies yet.
They're just over-densities of
gas.
Now, two things are going to
happen, since a redshift has
started by now.
One is that the box is going to
get thirty times bigger.
The whole Universe is going to
expand.
And that is included in the
simulation, but we're not going
to include it when we make the
movie, because it makes it hard
to see what's going on.
And so, if you'll remember the
coordinate system,
the way it works is there's
this scale factor times
x, y,
z position.
We're taking the scale factor
out.
So, this box is a single part
of the Universe.
It's going to expand by a
factor of 30,
but you're not going to see the
expansion here.
All you're going to see is the
motion in x,
y and z, not the
scale factor,
as these things moved toward
each other.
Now, as you start out,
it looks like it's pretty
evenly distributed,
but, in fact,
there are little perturbations
in the density.
And what will happen is the
galaxies will stream toward the
perturbations and the
perturbations will get bigger.
And the--keep track of redshift
up here.
The rate at which the redshift
changes, varies with time,
because what we're actually
counting, here,
is not redshift,
but time steps.
And the relationship between
time and redshift is not
obvious.
So, let us take another look at
the growth of structure,
here.
See them all moving towards
each other, collecting in these
filaments, abandoning whole
regions into voids.
And then, you end up--well,
you end up back where you
started, the way this film loop
works.
But let me show you a different
visualization of exactly the
same data.
You know, this is all on the
computer.
You can do anything you want.
They make these great things
where you sort of fly through
the Universe while it's evolving
and stuff.
I don't think--That's amusing,
but I don't think it's very
educational.
One thing that is useful:
they took that box and they
just kept rotating it as this
film looped right around it.
And that's useful,
because you get to see these
structures from different
angles, and I think it makes it
easier to visualize.
So, let's try that.
See, it's the same simulation,
except the box is rotating,
and so, you get a better sense,
I think, of what these
structures actually look like.
I'll do it once more.
As they collect into these
filaments and the filaments
collect together.
And so, what you can do with
the output of something like
this, with what it is at the
very end--whoops,
I missed.
Try it one more time.
Let me see if I can pause
before it gets--before it
regroups.
All right.
So, here is a small redshift.
When you get to this point,
there are mathematical ways of
saying, you know,
how clumpy is it?
How stringy is it?
And you can compare the results
of simulations of this kind with
actual observations from the
redshift surveys.
And so, in this particular
case, it worked.
So, let me go back to
here--yes--oh,
it's down here--whoops.
There we go.
There, that's where I want to
be for the moment.
And the consequence of these
kinds of things is,
it turns out that most,
as I said before,
mostly what you constrain,
and so, you compare the
simulations to redshift surveys.
And the consequence of that is
that you constrain the amount,
and also, to a lesser extent,
the type, the behavior,
of dark matter.
Because it's the matter that's
pulling things together.
And in a way,
you can think about these
little clumps and filaments.
That's places where the
Universe has already stopped and
contracted.
So, it had a little extra
density.
So, it hit--so,
it was beyond the critical
density.
And so, that little piece of
the Universe stopped and turned
around, even though the Universe
as a whole continues to expand.
All right, so, now.
What do we have?
Let's go back to the plot.
There's 1.
Here's 1.
And so, we have the supernovae
forcing you to be in this box,
here.
We have the Cosmic Microwave
Background forcing you to be in
this box, here.
And now, we're going to have a
straight vertical line in this
plot, because we know how much
dark matter there is from the
structure simulations.
Now, there are two
possibilities.
Supposing it comes in
here–this is a good answer,
because then,
everything is consistent.
Alternatively,
however, it could come in here.
This would be awkward,
because if it came in there,
there would be no answer that
would simultaneously satisfy all
of these constraints.
And so, then,
something is wrong either with
one of these determinations of
the cosmic parameters,
or with the theory as a whole.
Could be either observational
badness or theoretical badness.
And remember one – you know,
we did assume – in even
making this plot,
you're assuming that you're
dealing with a Cosmological
Constant as the form of the dark
energy.
And, as we discussed last time,
it's possible that it isn't
constant, that it's something
else.
And so, if you ended up--if
these things didn't work,
you'd have to ask yourself,
do I have any clue how the dark
energy works?
And the answer would be,
no, and you would kind of have
to abandon the Cosmological
Constant.
I think that's the easiest way
out if things don't work,
because dark matte--we don't
know what it is,
but we do know what it does.
It exerts gravity and pulls
things together.
So, no matter what the answer
to what it is,
its gravity will still be the
same.
Dark energy--not only do we not
know what it is,
we don't really know what it
does,
except that at the moment,
it's causing a certain amount
of acceleration.
And so, if you were satisfied
that all the observations were
right, you might also think that
your simulations have left out
something important.
That could easily be that you
don't fully understand how
structure evolves from a
Z of 3,000 to now.
That's certainly true at some
level, and so,
there are various ways you
could get out of it.
But the nice thing about it is
it's a test of cosmology.
Basically, if you have one
measurement of two variables,
the variables being the amount
of dark energy and the amount of
dark matter,
that doesn't tell you--all that
does is it establishes a
relationship between the two
variables.
It doesn't actually measure
either one of them.
And so, you get some allowed
region like this or this,
but you don't actually make a
measurement.
If you have two measurements of
two variable--if you think of it
in a mathematical sense,
this is two equations and two
unknowns.
This you can solve.
So, then, you measure values
for--well, in this case,
Ω_λ and
Ω_matter.
And that's nice.
Then, you can,
you know, quote what the values
are, once you've done this,
to however--whatever the
precision of your measurement
turns out to be.
If you have three measurements
of two variables,
that's a test of the theory,
because it is not guaranteed
that you'll get a consistent
result.
In general, if you write down
three lines in a two-dimensional
space, you don't pick out a
single point,
because they don't all cross at
the same place.
And so, if they do,
then you've got a consistent
result.
And then, you have tested the
theory because your prediction
is that all these three lines
cross at the same place.
They don't have to do that.
So, if you measure something
and it works out that way,
then you've tested the theory
and, kind of,
come out on top.
So, let me end today's class by
showing you the answer.
This is what we know about the
Universe.
Let's see, what have I done
with my--oh, there it is.
This is the allowed region of
the supernovae.
And what they've done is,
in each of the cases,
there's a sort of--I think it's
a one sigma region.
So, there's a 2/3 chance it'll
live inside here,
and a--;well,
over 90% chance that it lives
inside the broader area.
So, the supernovae force you to
be here.
The Cosmic Microwave Background
is the green result and it
forces you to be here.
And then, the clusters,
Large-Scale Clustering,
force you to be here,
and they cross.
So, this is the big triumph.
You've tested the theory by
measuring it in three different
ways for two parameters--namely,
the dark energy density and the
dark matter density.
Now, there are a couple other
interesting things to note on
this plot.
One is that,
in some cases,
the Universe expands forever,
and in some cases,
it re-collapses.
And we're well into the
expansion region.
There's also the question of
the geometry of the Universe.
The more stuff there is,
either dark energy or dark
matter, the more curved the
Universe becomes.
And so, you can ask yourself,
is the Universe curved in such
a way that it curves back on
itself?
Is it basically flat,
giving you Euclidian geometry,
or does it curve backwards and
extend infinitely?
And that's these three
situations, here.
If the sum is equal to 1,
then the Universe is flat and
Euclidian.
And so, that separates these
two.
Now, as somebody pointed out a
few classes ago,
if you have too much dark
energy, then you never cross 0.
And you never have a Big Bang,
because the acceleration has
been so great that you must have
started out coming down and been
bent up toward where we are now.
That's this region up here.
No Big Bang.
And so, we're well away from
that as well.
And so, this basically sums up
what we currently know about the
expansion of the Universe.
That we have a constraint going
this way, a constraint going
this way.
And you can see why I say that
in a kind of philosophical
sense, all three of these
measurements are equally
important,
because it's the fact that
you've got three of them that
allows a test of the theory.
And we've talked a lot about
the supernovae.
You could talk just as much
about the Cosmic Microwave
Background or about Large-Scale
Clustering,
and the comparison of
simulations with redshift
surveys.
We obviously aren't going to
have time to do it,
but this plot summarizes what
we know about the Universe.
Okay, thanks.